hagamos otro problema de identificación
de cónicas entonces tenemos 4 g cuadrada
menos 50 x es igual a 25 x cuadrada más
16 ye más 109 lo primero que me gustaría
hacer es agrupar todos los términos de
g&d x de un lado de la ecuación y dejar
todas las constantes del otro lado
hagámoslo
en el lado izquierdo pondré el 4g
cuadrada 4g cuadrada y de hecho agrupar
en todos los términos de x y en un solo
paso así que el 4g cuadrada pasemos este
16 al lado izquierdo de la ecuación así
que sí resto 16 g de ambos lados de la
ecuación obtengo menos 16 y menos 16 del
lado izquierdo y por supuesto éste
desaparecerá del lado derecho y ahora
arrestaré el 25 x cuadrada de los dos
lados de esta ecuación para obtener
menos 25 x cuadrada menos 50
x qué es esto de aquí y dejaré el 109
del lado derecho entonces es igual
y ahora que tengo las x y las yes del
mismo lado de la ecuación sabemos qué
tipo sabemos en qué dirección vamos
porque los tenemos del mismo lado y
tienen coeficientes diferentes uno es
positivo y el otro negativo lo cual nos
dice que estamos tratando con una
hipérbola ahora completemos los
cuadrados para llegar a la forma más
simple de la ecuación la forma más fácil
de completarlo es si tienen un
coeficiente en el término de cuadrada y
en el de x cuadrada factor hicimos un 4
en este caso así que queda
4 por de cuadrada menos 4 y más algo que
su madre después cuando complete el
cuadrado menos 25 por equis cuadrada más
déjenme ver menos 50 / menos 25 es dos
más dos x más algo que su madre después
es igual a 109
y esto que sumaremos es lo que
completará el cuadrado lo que hará esto
un cuadrado perfecto entonces si tomo
esto este menos cuatro lo divido a la
mitad
estoy completando el cuadrado los invito
a ver el vídeo de completar cuadrados
donde explico porque esto funciona pero
entonces tengo el menos cuatro y tomo la
mitad que es menos 2 y menos 2 al
cuadrado es más 4
pero no puedo hacerle algo a un solo
lado de la ecuación sin hacérselo
también al otro lado y no sólo sume 4 al
lado izquierdo sume 4 x 4 verdad porque
tenemos este 4 multiplicando a todo así
que sume 16 a este lado al lado
izquierdo entonces también tengo que
sumarlo al lado derecho
este es el equivalente a tener un +16
aquí tal vez esto lo hace un poco más
claro cierto cuando lo factorizar se
convierte en un 4 pero es como sumar 16
aquí
del mismo modo si tomamos la mitad de
este número aquí la mitad de 2 es 1 y 1
al cuadrado sigue siendo 1 pero no
sumamos un 1 al lado izquierdo de la
ecuación sumamos un 1 por menos 25 así
que debemos poner un -25 aquí e
igualmente esto sería lo mismo que haber
sumado menos 25 aquí arriba y ponemos
menos 25 aquí
y ahora en que se convierte esto estos
los términos de 10 se convierten en 4 y
menos 2 al cuadrado y menos 2
al cuadrado que se quieran repasar la
factorización de un polinomio si
encuentran un poco confuso este paso
menos 25 por x más 1 al cuadrado que es
esto de aquí x más 1 al cuadrado es
igual a veamos 109 más 16 es 125 menos
25 es igual a 100 ya casi lo tenemos
aquí queremos un 1 y para eso dividimos
todo entre 100 entonces obtenemos de
menos 2 al cuadrado
4 entre 100 es lo mismo que uno entre 25
entonces esto es sobre 25
- veamos 25 entre 100 es igual a un
cuarto entonces esto queda como x + 1
al cuadrado sobre 4 es igual a 1
y ahí lo tienen eso está en su forma más
simple y si tenemos una hipérbola ahora
graphic hemos la lo primero que sabemos
sobre esta hipérbola es donde está su
centro su centro está en el punto x
igual a menos uno está en x igual a
menos uno de igual a dos
ahora tratemos de encontrar las a
síntomas de esta hipérbola si ésta
estuviera esta es la forma en que
siempre lo hago porque nunca recuerdo la
fórmula si la hipérbola estuviera
centrada en el origen se vería algo así
y cuadrada sobre 25 - x cuadrada sobre 4
es igual a 1 hago esto para descubrir
cuáles serían las as into estás si esto
estuviera centrado en 0 porque es mucho
más fácil trabajar con este tipo de
ecuaciones que con estas así que
podríamos resolverlo multiplicando ambos
lados por 100
estamos tratando de repetir lo que
acabamos de hacer entonces si ustedes no
no de hecho multipliquemos ambos lados
por 25 para obtener
y cuadrada menos 25 cuartos de x
cuadrada
igual a
25 ahora seguiré por aquí y si ahora
sumó 25 cuartos de x cuadrada de ambos
lados me queda de cuadrada igual a 25
cuartos
x cuadrada más 25 y entonces que es
igual a más menos la raíz cuadrada de 25
cuartos
x cuadrada más 25
y como siempre las a sin total la
hipérbola nunca va a igualar a las a sin
total nunca las va a inter secar pero
estas son a lo que la gráfica se
aproxima
mientras x se aproxima a más y menos
infinito entonces mientras x
se acerca a más o menos infinito
y después aprenderán el concepto del
límite pero creo que mientras pueden
entender esto porque la idea de una sin
total es que mientras x se vuelve muy
grande aproximándose a esta línea
mientras x se acerca a infinito positivo
o negativo como hemos hecho en los
vídeos anteriores
este término empieza a importar muy poco
porque este otro es muy grande
y entonces ya es aproximadamente igual a
más menos la raíz cuadrada de solo este
término ahora la raíz cuadrada de este
término es 5 medios de x entonces esta
sería nuestra sasin total si
estuviéramos centrados en el origen pero
por supuesto estamos centrados en menos
1,2
entonces graphic hemos eso y después
podremos saber si la gráfica abre hacia
arriba o hacia abajo
el centro está en menos 12 déjenme ver
entonces quiero estar
este es mi hijo y este es el eje x y el
centro está en menos 1 en 12 ese es el
centro y éstas hubieran sido las asín
totas si el centro estuviera en 0 0 pero
esto nos dice la pendiente de las a sin
total además la tsa sin todas se van a
inter secar en el centro de nuestra
hipérbola
entonces por decir estas son las
pendientes de nuestras dos asín total y
15 medios positivos y cinco medios
significa que si avanzamos 212 en x
avanzamos 5 hacia arriba 1 2
45 y terminamos justo aquí ahora puedo
dibujar esa línea porque para dibujar
una línea solo necesito dos puntos la
línea se ve más o menos así
y la otra así en total tiene pendiente
menos cinco medios así que por cada dos
que nos movamos a la derecha nos
moveremos cinco hacia abajo entonces son
12 12
45 y acabamos aquí esta línea severa se
verá como esta
entonces estas son las dos asín total y
se extenderán al infinito en estas
direcciones y ahora podemos pensar de
dos maneras podemos decir ok
veamos si vemos la original no no veamos
esta si estuviera el centro en 0 x
podría ser igual a 0 bueno claro que
podría ser igual a cero si x es cero
entonces ya cuadrada sobre 25 es igual a
1 y cuadrada igual a 25 y ya sería igual
a más menos 5 cierto
así que en este caso para que este
término 60 x tendría que ser igual a
menos 1 si x es igual a menos 1 entonces
y menos 2 al cuadrado sobre 25 será
igual a 1 bueno hagamos eso veamos si x
es igual a menos 1 x
es igual a menos 1 entonces en que se
convierte esta expresión no quiero
perderlo así que lo escribiré por aquí
entonces teníamos que menos 2 al
cuadrado sobre 25
esto se vuelve 0 - 0 es igual a 1
entonces tenemos
- 2
al cuadrado sobre 25
es igual a 1
i
- 2
al cuadrado
es igual a 25 acabo de multiplicar ambos
lados por 25 g
- 2 es igual
más menos estoy sacando la raíz cuadrada
de ambos lados
5 entonces sí
- 2
es igual
a 5
- 2
es igual
- 5 sumando 2 a ambos lados de esta
ecuación obtenemos que igual
7 y sumando 2 a los dos lados de esta
ecuación tenemos que igual
a menos tres
entonces sabemos que los puntos menos
1,7
- 1,3 pertenecen a la gráfica entonces
menos uno está aquí uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete menos 17 y menos 112
menos tres están en la gráfica
esto nos deja saber que es como un tipo
de hipérbola vertical y otra forma de
adivinarlo es si se fijan en que el
término de cuadrada es positivo o la
otra forma de pensar lo es cuando
tomamos la raíz positiva siempre
estaremos un poquito arriba de la a sin
tota este es el otro modo de pensar esto
que siempre vamos a estar un poco y esta
es esta es la raíz positiva la raíz
positiva es la línea de arriba así que
siempre estaremos sobre ella
esta es la síntoma siempre estaremos un
poco por arriba de ella y es obvio que
este número se hace más grande y éste
empieza a importar mucho menos así que
la gráfica se verá algo así
mira hacia abajo
y después hacia arriba
nunca va a tocar a la cinta pero se va a
aproximar mucho se va a aproximar mucho
y después continuará en esa dirección
de cualquier manera espero que hayan
encontrado esto útil este fue un
problema más descabellado por lo que
debe ser instructivo